okay so we have to spend some time today
talking about the general election in
the United Kingdom late last week
because there is so much being said
about it and how it does or doesn't
relate to the upcoming 2020 election
here in the United States and Donald
Trump and Bernie Sanders and there's a
lot of interesting and good thoughtful
takes about this but there's also some
bad talking points and misinformation
that's being spread so let's start with
the facts what happened in the UK
trumpian
Conservative Party Prime Minister Boris
Johnson won with the Tories the
right-wing party getting a majority of
80 seats in the House of Commons
this truly is huge and it's especially
huge because the Tories had just lost
the majority back in 2017 and then
meanwhile a crushing defeat for the
Labour Party and its prime minister
candidate then leader who has since
resigned Jeremy Corbyn major losses
ended up with the lowest proportion of
seats since 1935 did the Labour Party
but a brutal defeat I mean that's the
only way I can really characterize it
and Jeremy Corbyn has resigned as the
head of the Labour Party now meanwhile
the Scottish National Party won a huge
victory in Scotland winning 48 of 59
seats that has some interesting
relationships to the Scottish
independence movement the brexit and the
view of brexit in Scotland and there's a
lot to discuss there as well so let's go
through it in pieces was this a
landslide for the right in the United
Kingdom it was absolutely is it a
crushing defeat for labour considering
that it is sort of the closest to the
modern American progressive movement of
Bernie Sanders and Elizabeth Warren it
is absolutely a crushing defeat for
labour in the UK but this is where a lot
of the analyses started to start to go
off the rails because when we think
further there are people saying this is
a signal what happened in the UK is a
signal that there is a rejection of the
Bernie Warren ideology and policy
prescriptions happening worldwide and it
signals that someone with Bernie or
Warren's platforms here in the United
States will get crushed in 2020 Trump is
going to win
the Democrats would be very very wrong
to go with someone like Bernie Sanders
or Elizabeth Warren because they can't
win as proven by the defeat of labour in
the UK this analysis is too simplistic
so let's try to flesh it out a little
bit and look at it more closely first of
all the starting point in the UK is a
much stronger social democracy then we
have here in the United States when you
look at the institutions that they
already have for example the UK already
has nationalized health care the NHS now
I know that there are some ideas of
Boris Johnson dismantling it but the
point is they've had it for a long time
it is popular voting for labour is not
how you might get such a system of
nationalized health care they have it
similarly on education in the UK on
other safety nets in so many other areas
these policies are already part of
British society so when you realize that
they already have these things labor
there is not like Bernie or Warren here
because here the left is trying to get
lots of things for the first time that
the UK already has so the stakes are
very different and therefore comparing
what happened to labour in the UK to a
Bernie Warren candidacy or presidency or
nomination on the Democratic side here
is not an apt comparison in that way in
the United States the people offering a
lot of those programs that are already
part of British society are the left
most of those running in the Democratic
Party whereas in the UK many of these
programs have been in place for decades
so labour being brutally defeated in the
UK which they were doesn't confirm that
the policy of Bernie Warren Social
Democrats is doomed to fail in the
United States now that gets us to labour
as a specific group of people Jeremy
Corbyn as a person versus Bernie Warren
etc having a candidate who was dogged by
allegations of coddling anti-semitism
not taking it seriously having unsavory
characters in their coalition and who
was seen as flaccid in his
sponses was not good now we don't need
to argue about each claim related to
anti-semitism because I know there are
people who say no look he did this
investigation into this anti-semitic
allegation we don't need to argue about
it I don't want to make this an
adjudication of each claim you can
research it for yourself without
adjudicating each claim I think we would
all agree that the allegations clouded
labor for a long time and they were not
definitively done away with in the eyes
of the voters and then further by the
way right after this election former
London Mayor Ken Livingstone who's a
former Labour Party MP who was actually
suspended over anti-semitism came out
and said I told you labour lost because
of the unhelpful Jewish vote which is
not only insane it's also mathematically
impossible there are roughly 400,000
Jews in the UK that includes children
that includes you know that that's
everybody and Corbyn lost the popular
vote by nearly 4 million votes so I
don't even know why I have to mention
that but obviously those types of claims
are absurd but they're exactly the type
of stuff that people are concerned about
labour had a cloud over it that is
specific to labour that being said I
have pointed out that Bernie's got some
problematic surrogates Linda Sarsour is
one also dogged with anti-semitism in
her past I think Bernie should separate
from her I just don't know that that is
going to take Bernie down this narrative
has not become a predominant one in the
United States Elizabeth Warren had a
racist homophobic trans black woman as a
surrogate we called her out I believe
she has been removed from the warran
campaign but what's not being mentioned
in all of this is brexit which is
looming over everything in the UK in a
way that it is not here in the United
States so in addition to the stakes
being different because of the social
programs that the UK already has in
addition to the cloud over Corbin being
very different than anything affecting
Bernie or Warren right now Labour's
position on brexit amounted to maybe
okay which is a very weak position and
probably didn't help them so what can we
glean from the UK results we can't say
Bernie Warren type politicians are dead
in the water because they're not we
can't say Americans don't want
progressive policy on health care and
education and corporate reform because
by
large the polls tell us that they do
what we do need to say is what I've been
saying for a year no matter what the
hypothetical matchups might say Trump
might absolutely crush everyone and we
need to fight for every single vote no
constituency can be assumed to be with
us until they go out and vote in 2020 we
can confirm that having a policy and a
set of ideas is vastly more important
than a grievance candidate or an anti
Trump candidacy that I think is a lesson
it was a right-wing landslide in the UK
but it's a cautionary tale about the
2020 election not it's time to throw in
the towel because Bernie Warren types
are obviously being rejected different
situation different electorate different
status quo and starting point and the
answer to it all is the same thing that
we knew before the UK election which is
get out the vote assume nothing and we
will actually have some interesting
polling later that confirms that all is
not well so to speak
but more on that coming up a little bit
later today's program brought to you in
part by Blink accom / Pakman blinka is a
great service that I use all the time
what they do is they take thousands of
the most popular non-fiction books
including the newest bestsellers they
condense them into 15-minute audiobooks
that you can listen to and you still get
the most crucial information and
insights from each book and I've
listened to a ton of books on blink Asst
I recently checked out
soccer na mcc's by Simon Cooper we do
have after all the World Cup going on
recently we also have been talking about
BS jobs and there is a great new book PS
jobs by David Graeber which I listened
to on bling cos they're constantly
adding new books to the platform you
will never run out of fascinating and
critically acclaimed books to enjoy and
our audience can get a seven day free
trial by going to blink accom slash
Pakman if you're watching on YouTube I'm
putting a link in the video description
and after the free trial if you like it
you can continue enjoying thousands of
condensed audiobooks for about five
bucks a month
that's bli and
hey is t.com /pa que mas